au loin la région occupée de personnes
devenue l'objectif affiché de ces
soldats ukrainien le rôle de ce petit
groupe d'officiers des dash et tenir
cette position près de mikko life dans
un village dévasté libéré de
l'occupation russe où l'on reste
constamment à l'affût des drones et nous
a perturbés hier ils ont frappé ici il
ya eu des explosions juste au dessus de
nous le matin les projectiles ont touché
le sol dans une voiture à 10 20 mètres
de notre ligne que la vigne la
contre-offensive vers ersonne se
confirme et kiev est optimiste le
président hélène ski a indiqué ce samedi
que les forces du craignent elles
regagnaient du terrain dans cette région
du sud de l'ukraine la première à être
tombés aux mains des russes au début de
la guerre
nous libère on raisonne c'est sûr dans
mon héros mons calenzana donneront pas
aux russes histoire de 15 m lire la
torah c'est pourquoi nous sommes ici
pour que nous puissions en finir avec
cette guerre
et pour de manière à aider de systèmes
de lance-roquettes américain d'une
portée de 80 km les forces du craignait
n'ont pu détruire des stocks d'armes et
des postes de commandement ennemi mais
kiev cherche surtout à isoler les
troupes russes déployées dans la région
en ciblant le pont d'antonov ski points
de ravitaillement vers la crim est
essentiel pour les troubles du kremlin
les autorités ukrainiennes affirme
désormais que la région sera
définitivement libérée d'ici septembre